[Música]
pero no de esa forma
para que me mataran
yo necesito pues que ellos se pongan a
pensar que lo que están haciendo
d
qué
es decir a los dedos
en tu punto de vista de los agentes que
llevaron a cabo este arresto hubo uno
específicamente hubo uno o fueron todos
los que cometieron esa violencia contra
ti o hubo uno más de los tres que te
pusieron en el suelo
[Música]
si lo despedían de su cara
porque yo había dicho cosas pero yo le
dije que yo estaba diciendo
[Música]
no voy a decir mentiras lo que él me
hizo y me dijo de que él tenía
experiencia siempre
[Música]
pero eso pasó eso es fue un agente que
fue participó en el arresto
se había arrestado
aunque
[Música]
ah
y lo que me hicieron miles
sí
en toda esa carretera por tanta
migración a la paz
sin mi ropa
en mi medicina un doctor que está ellos
para dar
que la perdiste quiere saber si tus
viste en el momento que ellos cortaron
la malla para sacarte por ahí tú estabas
ahí o cuando llegas viajaba
[Música]
yo me palpó donde estaban
y
[Música]
min
vida
ok